ok I got a voicemail that actually it's
it's sort of a I don't know if it's a
troll or someone just trying to
instigate but they actually bring up
something really important that I've
discussed before so let's take a listen
to it I'll remind you our voicemail
number is two one nine to david p a few
reminders with peace and love if you
leave a three-minute voicemail and get
cut off and call back because you had
something that was longer than three
minutes and you have to finish it the
voicemail is not getting played we've
never played these 3-minute voicemails
on the show so keep them pithy keep them
short get right to the point let's take
a listen to this one that came in
overnight hey David I was curious how
you and other self-described progressive
punting on YouTube are content with
profiting off though first of all the
word is pundit not pun dent but go ahead
right wing controversy while
simultaneously decrying the far-right
for example you Sam cedar kyaku MP The
Young Turks etc are arguably their
biggest platform for example you felt
compelled to appear on Jesse Lee
Peterson show not only once but twice
because somehow appearing on a racial
sellout podcast there's gonna help the
civil discourse in America then you also
interviewed Richard Spencer a literal
Nazi that bench of Parowan and most
recently Sam Harris who's a race realist
and is on record saying people just
don't know how to get arrested
quote-unquote in response to racial
profiling in the US how is this not more
counterproductive than beneficial to the
free marketplace of ideas and civil
discourse in America thank you so listen
there's a bunch of different issues here
that that we need to discuss first of
all this idea of profit you're against
right-wing ideas but you profit by
criticizing them that I did I just don't
even understand that arguments like oh
you're an environmental cleanup company
advocating for corporations to be more
careful so that they don't destroy the
environment you're against environmental
destruction but you're profiting from
cleaning it up I mean it it's that
that's a very very weak argument I think
the more interesting question here is
one of responsible platforming and of
making decisions
sort of for the greater good I've said
this before when we do a show we do a
mix of Policy Analysis things like what
should government regulation of social
media look like and we spend a half hour
dealing with that and we do comments
about you know stories about Trump's
latest unhinged tweets or whatever my
approach has always been we want to do
the most good possible and part of doing
the most good possible is having the
largest possible audience while still
being able to do the stories we want to
do so when we do the story about Trump's
erratic tweets or Trump's erratic rally
or whatever it is not the deepest most
important policy analysis but it gets a
lot of attention and it brings people
into our universe who then are in our
universe when we do the policy analysis
about government regulation of social
media or comparing different health care
plans and different ways in which
Medicare for all could be implemented or
whatever so I find it to be you know
there's this guy named Karl Benjamin you
might know him a sargon of akkad he once
accused me of using clickbait youtube
titles and I brought him on a couple of
years ago and I said it sounds like what
you're accusing me of doing is picking
YouTube's titles that will make people
want to watch the videos if the titles
are accurate it's called marketing to
choose titles that are more likely to
make someone want to watch the video
then less likely to want to watch the
video I don't think there's anything
wrong with that and and only a very sort
of myopic framework would really focus
on those as the issues now with regard
to me interviewing Richard Spencer this
is a long-standing debate which is what
am I really doing by interviewing an
extremist and the answer is are they
being responsibly platformed or are they
being given a platform to uncritically
spout propaganda which may actually
convince people to come over to their
side or whatever the case may be people
can disagree about this but we've been
talking about this for years I believe
that if I am well-prepared
to refute bad ideas and the ideas are
prominent enough that there is some
benefit to refuting them or exposing
them or whatever the case may be I have
no problem with responsibly platforming
those people and just mentioning the
marketplace of ideas or whatever that's
just a talking point it doesn't actually
mean anything and these these talking
points being repeated ad nauseam does
nothing to actually allow us to think
critically about what are the goals of
independent media what are the sort of
guidelines that independent media should
responsibly adhere to so if you were
just trolling then I guess I fell for it
and I answered it like it was a serious
question I think you raised totally
valid questions what is responsible
platforming what is the goal of
independent media shows what is the line
between marketing honestly to get
people's attention versus being
deceptive right and these are all
debates that are individual they are
different I'm willing to have all of
them they're all legitimate and if
you're a good faith actor wanting to
discuss them I invite you to call into
the show and we can talk more about it
make sure to remember that the voicemail
number is two one nine two david p we've
got a fantastic bonus show for you today
Donald Trump now says that homelessness
is hurting what he calls real estate
prestige we'll discuss that on the bonus
show we will talk about Richard Stallman
a free software pioneer who I have
interviewed before he has quit his role
at the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology MIT because of some comments
he made on a listserv about Jeffrey
Epstein's case and we will also talk
about the resurgence of the mayor Pete
versus Beto battle on gun control it's
not a battle that will be consequential
in terms of the Democratic primary
neither one of them has a shot but it's
interesting nonetheless all of those
stories and much more on today's bonus
show two ways to get instant access
become a member at join join pakman.com
or become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I'll speak to you on
the bonus show or otherwise if you don't
get access to the bonus show sadly I
will still be
right back here tomorrow with a brand
new show